you guys want to talk about
authoritarianism you don't talk about
fascism you'll talk about all that stuff
how about this story from ctv news
man charged with assault at montreal
quarantine
woman says she felt helpless you don't
get you don't get enough of
understanding from this headline
let me tell you what happened a woman
heard they were going to start
instituting mandatory quarantines in
canada
she decided i'll go back to canada now
before they do this took a covet test
when she arrived it said that was the
wrong covid test so they took her to an
undisclosed location
a hotel they told her she wasn't allowed
to tell anyone where she was
where the hotel was or what was going on
and while she was there a man sexually
assaulted her
this is authoritarianism this is what we
have to worry about with
with these passports with these
lockdowns i watched a video
it was from rebel news i don't know
don't know a whole lot about it but i
saw this video on twitter
and it's a it's a one of their reporters
is walking down the street filming
probably my assumption is he was filming
like this is what the lockdown looked at
looks like you know i'm out here showing
the people and the cops gave him a fine
and said we don't care they wrote him a
ticket curfew for an adult man
walking down an empty street now listen
i mentioned that
that's not the worst of it this story
was sent to me
and at first i was like what what is
this a guy's being charged sexual
assault at montreal quarantine hotel
women says she felt helpless what is
this
and she said she felt helpless at a
hotel where she didn't expect to end up
and where she was told she wasn't
allowed to disclose her location quote
they didn't tell you where they were
taking you
which is unacceptable they gave a set of
rules can't post on social media
can't disclose location federal health
officials told ctv they're aware of the
incident and taking it very seriously
the assault that's what they care about
to the rest of these people it's normal
that this woman was flying back to her
home and was apprehended by the
authorities for breaking no crime
told she couldn't tell anyone what was
going on she couldn't report anything on
social media she couldn't give her
location out they brought her to an
undisclosed location where she was
assaulted
what this is insane they're literally
taking people
who have broken no laws right locking
them up
it's also and the problem with all of
this too is
it's the case in canada i'm sure it's
certainly the case in the united states
when you empower government to do things
right
we've seen this with a patriot actually
there's lots and lots of things when you
allow governments to have lots and lots
of power and lots and lots of authority
that is relatively unchecked
against everyday life and against
everyday civilians they don't give them
back quickly right we've
the coronavirus cases are down like 75
77 percent i think in the last couple of
weeks right
and despite that has your life changed
has have any has anyone's life changed
fair we're in the middle of nowhere yeah
we don't yeah that's a good point you
guys say i i live in dc and so it's a
whole
nothing's changed everyone's wearing
people are wearing two masks instead of
one now that's the only thing that's
drive all the razor wire and the
yes yeah yeah i went for a run the other
day because i used i used to run and i'd
run up
up to the cap because i lived pretty
close there no i mean it's it's
it's as if we're living it's like east
west germany it's insane but
what happens when government gets these
powers is that a
bureaucracy that is empowered to make
these sorts of decisions is always going
to think they are going to make the
right decision
they are not going to give you the power
and authority back and it has been i
think to me really incredible
despite the fact that the cases are
falling and deaths are falling
life isn't actually returning to normal
in all of the places where all of these
lockdown restrictions have been put in
place
and canada obviously is a nightmarish
example of this
but we're not that far from this kind of
no we're not and what is fauci saying
look if you go get the vaccine nothing's
going to change
you'll still have to wear two masks you
won't be able to go to the movies or go
out to eat
so go get it anyway and people are
actually not a questioning why would
they do it
who's going to do that and here's the
thing too like listen if all he would
say it blows my mind because all he
would have to do
absent this power conversation if he's
someone who just wants to see people get
the vaccine you know what you do you
tell them how great the vaccine is yeah
we have managed in the span of a very
limited amount of time
to come up with a revolutionary virus
because of the power of american r d
in research that can vaccinate
evolutionary vaccinations
that can stop and shut down a pandemic
that has brought the world to its knees
go get it it's safe we've tested it a
gazillion times go get the vaccine well
the long-term tests
haven't been done yeah it takes a while
yeah i i
i don't want to get into that another
thing i wanted to bring up is before
you know forcing the the strictest
lockdowns the canadian government also
disarmed a large public of the canadian
citizenry and we had politicians like
justin trudeau that was
in october of 2020 telling its citizenry
don't believe the conspiracy theories
that there's going to be government
quarantine camps it's a conspiracy
theory
don't believe it it's not going to
happen and
here we are today when you enter canada
it's not a camp
it's a sheraton hotel
of course corrupt security guards that
do unspeakable things to you
and i mean i mean this is just
it's just it's like the frog boiling
that's essentially what's happening here
and there's still a lot of legitimate
questions surrounding the vaccine that i
do believe should be asked
from my own personal opinion yeah you
would think that with like a kind of
like a propaganda campaign in favor of
the vaccine that people like dr fauci
would be
super raw raw about it i don't know
trump did it he's not
trump did it and they're they don't like
that that's it that's it that's fine i
mean look
we mentioned this before all these
stories were coming out saying like oh
boogeyman vaccine a doctor took a
vaccine two weeks later was dead
and then i read the stars like wow what
happened and it was like he had a stroke
oh two weeks later he had a stroke okay
come on i'm concerned about the
the the the you know the speediness at
with which this vaccine was put out
there
but i'm worried that there are the same
nasty unethical journalists who are like
it's trump's vaccine though
you know let's rag on it let's let's i
mean
and the politicians certainly like the
power so i i wonder why it is fauci is
saying these things
maybe he's being honest maybe it really
isn't that effectual or he doesn't know
well there's yeah maybe maybe they did
it because they were scared and people
needed hope so the vaccine is worthless
is that what she's saying well again
this is
rushed this is still experimental and
there have been some findings saying
that if you do get the vaccine you could
still spread the sickness there's been
studies saying that there's been experts
saying that i think even
you have to look this up correct me if
i'm wrong i think even fauci said this
himself so
when we're looking at you know i don't
think this is trump's vaccine this is
pfizer's vaccine this is modernism this
is johnson and johnson's vaccine and it
was operation
speed that trump streamlined the process
to ramp everything through really really
quickly and provide massive funding for
all this
guarantee but when people look at it now
they don't see trump uh
that's that's the point that i'm making
here yes trump played a key initiative
uh in in pushing this vaccine uh but the
questions about its efficacy and its
safety
those still are kind of questions that
are being asked
and we'll see yeah and and dr fauci is
the one who's basically undermining
confidence in it
yeah and that that to me is is insane
yeah
and like and to me again like at the
risk of being a little bit black
helicopters on this stuff
i think part of it is if he were to go
out and say that it is fully effective
and fully safe and everyone should get
out and do it
then people would probably start stop
looking to the cdc for advice
right like if you look at all of the
different things that the cdc recommends
you do most of us ignore them on a
day-to-day basis
right how many like how many people
truly go and they're like well you know
i really like the taste of medium rare
steak but
the cdc says you have to cook it to at
least medium no one people don't do they
really say that yes that's one of the
recommendations
and i think it's like it's like it's
like one or two drinks is the maximum
like they have all of these like they
have a litany they have a litany of very
very silly rules that no one actually
follows this is for
and i think no for anything they're
telling people to ruin their steaks
yes exactly who do we impeach
thank you thank you but here's the thing
right now we right now people are it's
in a lot of ways it's like the weather
men when they predict storms right
as long as they keep telling you that a
storm is coming you're gonna be glued
you're gonna pay attention
i'm gonna i'm gonna go to the weather
channel and see if it if we're gonna get
six inches or eight inches or 12 inches
or is it going to be worse
is it going to be nothing but if you
keep saying ah something bad and scary
is coming around the corner
people will keep tuning in i mean and in
his case people will keep empowering him
and the rest of the agents of the state
to be able to say oh sorry you can't do
the things we don't like
it's an addiction yeah you've got people
who have power and they've found a way
to use government to gain more power be
it money
shutting down all our competition and
allowing only us to remain open we're
not going to oppose that
and so unless there is a principled
individual to snap their fingers and say
stop this
which there isn't right why would anyone
give this up now listen
the people running the big box stores
and the big massive you know
online stores who are allowed to stay a
lot of stay open and are making all this
money and
making billions and billions of dollars
they're going to be like well look it's
not
us it's the pandemic so we're not going
to get involved i think elon was pretty
good about being like this thing's
ridiculous i'm not shutting my factory
down i'm leaving california
come with me he needs people driving
their cars so i'm not trying to impugn
in the honor of elon
but if people are staying home they're
not buying cars they're not driving cars
so it's good for tesla and it's good for
their bottom line when people are out
and about
you look at amazon it's the inverse they
need you in your home waiting for that
delivery
so why would they resist in any capacity
these politicians are also thinking
i got a guaranteed salary and everyone
is sitting there terrified
and will do whatever i say sounds good
to me yeah
if people lose their livelihoods who's
going to buy teslas so that's another
thing to really consider here as well as
on the other hand
we did had a job john hopkins doctor
recently come out in the wall street
journal
journal op-ed and write that covid's
going to be over by april
we had the independent reporting that
there has been no influenza cases
in the united kingdom all year there
also has been a huge
influenza drop in the united states and
according to english health officials
and the deputy chief medical officer of
the united kingdom he is even saying
as of two days ago that face masks may
not even be necessary by the summer so
this is also happening as well
as the same time as we're discussing you
know dark
predictions and dr fauci's opposite
viewpoint
of what all these other medical
professionals are saying in other
countries did you say there was no
influenza in the united kingdom yes
according to the british uh uh
the the uk health records there was uh
zero cases of influenza of flu in the
united kingdom this year 2021.
let's uh let's talk about this not a
single case of flu detected by public
health england this year
as covetous restrictions suppress virus
experts say decline in infections
could justify continued use of hand
sanitizer and masks following
chronovirus pandemic
that's really amazing that kovid was
skyrocketing while the flu is
disappearing yeah are you trying to fact
check me there ian i want to just point
this out good i like that i like that
we should be fact-checking the influenza
is being is
present but they're not classifying it
as an influenza infection instead
they're saying it's a covalent oh well
we don't know that
no we don't know that i'd like to
investigate that but it does raise
an important question similar uh numbers
have gone down in the united states so
there's another article
uh that i was just reading a couple days
ago about influenza almost totally wiped
out in the united states there still
have been some documented cases
now now again we don't have the evidence
it's it's a stretch
to to go there but but some people are
going there
but again this is something to to think
about this is something to add to our
calculations when we're
looking at the sphere of our current
modern day
the flu when people were staying home
couldn't spread
but covet could but it wouldn't mean
that you wouldn't get it like yeah it
would slow the spread but that doesn't
mean it doesn't exist it's interesting
what i had heard in terms of influence
of coming to the united states is that
there's essentially and
listen someone's got to fact-check me on
this but i think the argument is that
influenza the annual influenza tends to
come from central and south america
yeah uh and that every like it it
cultivates there for whatever reason
right and don't forget
the the seasonal flu we get now is just
a dilapidated version of the 1918
spanish flu
um and it just it never quite went away
and that's kind of how they assume that
it keeps community too
right and so every year we get like a
slightly like a slight variance
on a new strain and for whatever reason
my understanding is that i don't know
where it starts but it tends to come to
the united states from central and south
america
since there's a lot less tourism there's
a lot less immigration i think the
thinking is that it hasn't actually kept
its normal course so you're saying that
migrant caravans are putting out
we have to lock the borders down but
there's one argument that's only i'm
only half kidding i mean that's
that's true too like if that if if the
flu is really coming from
you know a lot of these people then
border security would help prevent a lot
of these
i do think it's about i think it's
mostly tourists though i think it is
it tends to work but also interesting
point you made earlier is about this
wall street journal open which i read
the other day i found fascinating
and basically the crux of his argument
is we're not taking into account how
many people
already have a natural resistance to the
vaccine because there have been so many
asymptomatic cases i think his estimates
are that
there have been between five and six
times as many people who have been
infected by coronavirus than our numbers
have
not for any malicious reason but just
because um a lot of people were
asymptomatic had it never got tested
never even thought to get tested never
even knew they had it yeah of course and
never knew that they had it
and so um the when we talk about herd
immunity one of the biggest factors is
that in the case of this op-ed the
argument is that one of the biggest
things we're not talking about is
how many people have natural immunity
and so if instead of
a million or a couple of million it's a
lot higher than that
then you don't actually have to
vaccinate as many people until you get
to a point where the numbers continue to
fall and continue to fall to a point
where they're almost vanishing yeah most
of them by the way have healthy immune
systems have good vitamin d levels again
something that we should be talking
about more
there was also another uk study that
talked about how the vaccine won't
eliminate the virus risk
i think it was also in the wall street
journal that reported this as well which
was kind of interesting vaccine won't
eliminate
uh virus risk i think was the title i
don't know if you're able to find it or
pull it up there
but again there's so many different
things being
thrown at us that we have to understand
all of this is extremely
complex a lot of the experts contradict
themselves a lot of the mainstream media
reports sensationalize it make it as
hyperbolic make it as fearful as they
can for you
and a lot of the real legitimate things
about your health your immune system
sleep stress proper diet exercise
vitamin d sun a lot of that gets missed
yeah again not a medical doctor not a
medical professional not telling you how
to leave your life not telling you what
to do
but i'm just saying that this whole
conversation around this from
the very beginning has been toxic has
been polluted and has been politicized
so that people take advantage of it for
their own personal benefit and sadly
our politicians did that to us thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time